season four of stranger things might
just be the best season yet but
splitting it into two parts has left
fans with a ton of questions as they
wait for part two to drop what will
eleven's powers look like now is there
hope for vekno's victims keep watching
for the biggest head scratchers of the
season so far in season three's epic
finale hopper appears to sacrifice
himself to close a gate to the upside
down but fans knew that they hadn't seen
the last of hawkins police chief and
their hopes were confirmed when netflix
released a teaser trailer for stranger
things season 4 that revealed hopper not
only survived the explosion but also
ended up in russia somehow
i gotta hand it to you
you're committed
the first part of season 4 spends quite
a bit of time with hopper as he's
interrogated by russian soldiers and
sent off to a prison camp hopper
befriends a less than loyal prison guard
and begins plotting his escape through
all of this the show stubbornly refuses
to explain exactly how hopper traveled
from hawkins to russia sure it could be
as simple as the russians carefully
smuggled him out of the country but this
is stranger things we're talking about
so there may be more to it than that the
answer likely has everything to do with
the mysterious connection between
hawkins and the upside down and fans can
only hope that volume 2 of season 4 will
finally provide some answers
a new big bad has made its way from the
upside down to hawkins to terrify the
town the gang calls this new threat
vecna after a dark wizard and a dungeons
and dragons campaign who can cast curses
on his foes becna is causing his victims
to have vivid hallucinations and when
those horrible visions become strong
enough he uses his powers to crumple
their bodies and remove their eyeballs i
don't know what this freak did to
chrissy but he did something sick these
are some of the most gruesome deaths in
all of stranger things but there might
be a way for becnus victims to be saved
when max is pulled into the upside down
during one of echno's imposed visions
she gets a closer look into what the
wizard appears to be doing max sees the
bodies of ekno's victim strung up on
pillars and later the group wonders if
vecna is using them to increase his own
psychic powers in chapter 7 one tells 11
that his victims are still alive in his
mind is it possible that the same is
true of the people he killed as vecna if
so there might be a way to save everyone
retroactively it's a long shot but in
the world of stranger things it wouldn't
be that crazy
becna's curse is terrorizing hawkins and
anyone afflicted with the curse begins
having visions tied to their past trauma
threaded throughout those visions are
images of an antique grandfather clock
after seeing the clock several times
anyone with the visions comes face to
face with bechden himself in the vision
vechna puts his claw over his victim's
head and does something to their mind
meanwhile in the real world the victim's
body is lifted into the air and crumpled
like a ball of paper before the eyes get
removed the violence of the murders and
the seeming randomness of those targeted
sends the entire town into a panic
these murders are ritualistic sacrifices
the main stranger thinks gang becomes
even more concerned with stopping the
attacks when one of their own is
afflicted by the curse max thinks that
her hours are numbered when she starts
seeing becnus visions her friends
realize that by playing her favorite
music at the peak of beckham's attack
max is able to find a way to escape the
vision and survive unfortunately that
doesn't break her curse entirely and max
remains a target for vechna hopefully
they'll find a true cure for the curse
in volume 2 of season 4.
when hopper shows up in russia it
becomes clear that the soviet union has
a deeper connection to the upside down
than anyone had previously assumed as
surprised as hopper is to find himself
alive not to mention halfway across the
world from hawkins his biggest surprise
is just around the corner it turns out
that there's a special plan in place for
some of the prison's most problematic
residents the russians have a demogorgon
they've been feeding batches of
prisoners to
you know why they feed captive predators
live prey
because if they don't the predator gets
bored
the demogorgon brings up a whole slew of
new questions for stranger things fans
to puzzle over it looks like the
russians plan on using the demogorgon as
a weapon and if that's the case why is
it hanging out inside a remote prison
and how did they manage to capture a
democorgan in the first place
the exact link between 11 and the upside
down is one of the biggest mysteries in
all of stranger things her abilities
have opened and closed gates to that
alternate reality but it's never been
clear whether or not those abilities
have any definite cause and effect
connection to the world that haunts
hawkins this season more than any other
has highlighted the fact that 11 and the
upside down are intertwined in ways that
are still being worked out some american
scientists like dr owens believe that
eleven's powers can stop the evil forces
at work in the upside down and finally
bring peace to hawkins others think that
eleven is the cause of all the trouble
and right now it looks like their
argument might have more evidence
backing it in the last episode of volume
one eleven seemingly opens the first
gate to the upside down when she defeats
one there are still too many unknowns to
put this question to rest but the answer
will probably have a big impact on the
fate of everyone in hawkins
all of the drama in stranger things
ultimately circles back to hawkins
indiana when evil starts climbing its
way into the real world it always seems
to break through hawkins first despite
having learned so much about the upside
down through years of conflict no one in
hawkins appears to have figured out why
their town is a hot spot for
supernatural disasters
some people they they say our town is
cursed they just don't know why hawkins
connection to the upside down clearly
has something to do with 11 dr brenner
and the experiments with superpowered
children right now though that
connection is like the chicken and egg
question is hawkins plagued by evil
because 11 opened the gate to the upside
down in the town or did that gate open
because the upside down was always
connected to the town
dr brenner aka papa returns in the
middle of this run of episodes eleven's
life has completely changed in the years
since she last saw him and from the
looks of it his life has changed quite a
bit too in season one dr brenner seemed
like an obvious antagonist for the show
however now he's apparently working on
behalf of 11. dr brenner is helping her
regain her powers but he hasn't said
anything about his reasons for doing so
or what he's been doing since he left
hawkins whatever dr brenner has been
doing will have a big impact on what
happens to eleven and the people of
hawkins it seems like he's joined the
faction of the government that believes
11 can save the town and bring an end to
the upside down forever but we can't be
too sure that's the case after all dr
brenner is the one who experimented on
11 and the other children in the first
place
he's obviously put much of his energy
into creating the facility that will
help eleven regain her powers but what
is his real motivation for doing so
don't rule dr brenner out as a villain
just yet
you chose to trust me once
i'm asking you to trust me again
chapter 7 packs in some major reveals
including the true story of what
happened to the children who were used
for experiments alongside 11. now it
appears that one was the first child to
display powers and it's possible that dr
brenner and the other scientists somehow
used one to create other superpowered
children somehow eleven's powers became
even more potent than ones because when
the two square off she is able to defeat
him and rip open a gate to the upside
down in the process
while one may have been defeated he
isn't dead somehow he's able to survive
in the upside down and his survival
transforms him into the creature known
as vecna does one's survival imply some
connection between his powers and the
upside down was he possibly saved by the
mind player the answers aren't clear but
they'll probably come to light as the
gang finds a way to put an antivectous
murderous rampage through the town
during most of stranger things season 4
volume 1 eleven is on a mission to
regain her powers sam owens and a group
of government agents ask eleven to come
with them so they can help her get her
powers back to save hawkins eleven
agrees only to later discover that dr
brenner is working with owens for once
it seems like dr brenner is one of the
good guys as he helps 11 to uncover some
of the traumatic memories that her mind
has forced her to forget eleven's lost
powers are somehow linked to her lost
memories but the true significance of
that connection remains unclear in the
final episode of volume one eleven
remembers her battle with one and
everything else that happened to her at
the hawkins lab does that mean she now
has her powers back or will she end up
getting new powers the answers when they
come will probably reveal more about the
origin of eleven's powers in the future
of hawkins
supernatural happenings take center
stage and stranger things but this
season the romantic drama has also been
dialed up all of our favorite characters
might be involved in life or death
battles for the fate of their entire
town but they also have love on their
mind mike and eleven have a big fight
right before she leaves to regain her
powers so their relationship is
currently in question
similarly jonathan and nancy struggle to
make long distance work and steve's
feelings for nancy are bubbling back to
the surface
it's not just current couples who are
struggling in the romance department max
broke up with lucas between seasons but
there's still an obvious spark of
feelings between them will seems to be
struggling with complicated feelings
from mike and his mother ran off to
russia to save hopper so there are
romantic possibilities all over the
globe
sometimes
i think it's just scary to open up like
that
obviously stopping becna and saving the
world is everyone's top priority on who
could blame any of them for having other
concerns
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one